[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu la chance l'année dernière de
jouer avec monsieur georges descrières
de la comédie française une pièce
classique de molière dont jure j'avais
le rôle de ce canard elle est monsieur
des critères m'a dit tu vois maintenant
quand tu fais la baisse il sur scène au
music hall ce serait peut-être de bon
goût de dire une petite chose classique
aussi parce qu'il paraît que ça donne de
la classe en détiennent ne savions pas
que alors si vous le permettez mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs je veux dire
une petite un petit poème de paul
claudel intitulé oui oui
non
riez pas claudel ça va avec toute sa
classe c'est tiré du soulier de satin
sur le début du deuxième acte à poèmes
intitulé oui oui non non tu ne les
reverras plus les étapes au n
classique classique c'est un drame c'est
le drame d'une femme ballon mais c'est
le drame d'une femme qui a une fuite à
sa baignoire
c'est pas la peine d'écrire
applaudissaient
mais j'aime réservés
monsieur pradines vous coupez les
laissez nous faire entre nous
c'est le rire ça n'ont jamais dû alors
c'était donc c'est donc le problème le
drame d'une femme qui a une fuite à sa
baignoire et qui a un perroquet c'est de
paul claudel et cette dame
alors commencez pas un homme on n'est
pas si pourri gaulle et s'il vous plaît
à savoir si je vais y arriver
cette dame qui est un perroquet qui a
une fille à sa baignoire
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on n y fit à
sa baignoire en téléphone au très bien
et le plombier lui dit à la dame qui a
le perroquet coup de main je suis navré
vous me demander de venir immédiatement
malheureusement j'ai beaucoup de travail
je ne peux pas venir tout de suite mais
je viendrai en fin d'après midi
c'est embêtant vouliez prendre un bain
avec que je voulais je vous dise madame
moi j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de travail en
ce moment non je n'en veux pas venir
tout de suite non mais je vous promets
que je viens en fin d'après-midi pas que
tu donnes ont assisté par une havre et
je présente mes hommages madame
n'insistait pas vous
et la dame qui a le perroquet ce débat
puisqu'il vient en fin d'après midi
j'ai tout mon temps je vais faire
quelques emplettes et la dame sort de
son appartement
laissant à l'intérieur de son logis sans
paix en raid
et c'est là où est la subtilité
l'histoire jean rostand d'ailleurs en
avant les prêts longuement avec jean
nohain
a la sorbonne au cours d'un colloque
ils n'ont jamais pu élucider le mystère
suivant c'est que le plombier au moment
mais je vous en supplie de manquer une
communion entre nous parce que là c'est
très important c'est qu'au moment où le
plombier raccroche l'appareil
il se dit je me suis ridicule j'ai
complètement oublié que je devais passer
devant son domicile pour aller faire mes
gros travaux que j'ai à faire pour
boucher un trou de baignoire il y en a
pour une seconde je vais y aller
directement parce que ça se rappelle pas
même pas téléphoné doublage journée
ville morte chez elle à coup de
chalumeau lui prend dix sacres a dit
michel debré
[Applaudissements]
un beau sapin
poirier merci beaucoup
je vais y aller directement à tomber
madame mouchabeurre c'est bien ici il
frappe à la porte
une voix l'intérieur fait qu un arrêt
c'est le premier à huy
l'envié
ça va pas là mais mais un seul clavier
un quart d'heure après essai soyez
chouette j'ai du boulot aux voix moi je
te porte du coin d'un feu de paille ou
vraiment la foi je rame chéreau jeu mais
plein de plans plein votre exemple je
suis un plombier un gentil plombier
il n'y a pas plus gentil que les
plombiers
et je suis à sept premiers qui
synthétiques sont pas pleins les yeux
[Applaudissements]
une demi-heure après qui sait
le report des voix
on a été pris par le groupe
qui s'était dit super plan b une heure
après qui sait
c'est plat plat
m
[Musique]
la dame qui avait été faire ses
emplettes remonte ses escaliers
elle voit un type complètement écroulé
sur son paillasson bien la dame qui fait
qui sait il ya une voie l'intérieur qui
répond ce clavier
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas trop longtemps
bonjour monsieur taille elle c'est moi
c'est moi qui suis venu il ya deux jours
chercher mon costume vous souvenez moi
je m'excuse de vous demander pardon
seulement c'est les copains ils m'ont
dit ton nouveau costume sais pas qui tu
va mal il va même bien au premier abord
seulement au deuxième rapport or car
dans bien ils m'ont dit il la là il y
aurait comme un défaut ça nous
étonnerait pas entrer dans mon cher à
nous eh bien on peut dire je vous ai
fait un beau gosse tu vas loin
et puis du boty sur ta témoin ça c'est
du nylon réponse
il pleut saab sorte où vous êtes
contents du tissu 5,5 qui suce 80 rames
gens sortent de loi une eau non
seulement c'est les copains parce que
vous savez ça va vous paraît curieux
vous met dans le milieu où je vis moi
avoir un costume neuf c'est un événement
le soir au bar tabac
il ya tous les copains qui sont alors
faut offrir l'apéritif ça s'arrose
alors les potes ils sont la tombe d'un
pont power marche un peu pour qu'on se
rende compte
tu peux alors ils mendient dans le dos
tu n'as pas tellement de malheurs de 20
alors là tu l'as dans le dos et la
doublure de l'aca tinette de maubeuge
mélangé avec du trèbes de chine et le
crêpe de chine faut payer le voyage
dites moi pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
contents de la doublure mais j'ai aimé
jamais dit ça la doublure le tissu tout
je suis content sommes ensemble c'est
une éco penly non dit là il ya comme un
défaut je voulais pas vous dire monsieur
au début je voulais pas vexé mais vous
vous tenez mal ce costume que j'ai fait
est impeccable mais si vous vous tenez
mal forcément qu'il y aura comme un
défaut naïve comme première boeing comme
bien si regardez vous dans la glace et
tenez vous droit un homme que diable
enlevez l'épaule gauche un centième de
relever les prix s'en tiennent un quart
de poil la voyez tout de suite la
différence
c'est ma foi vrai si je relève l'épaule
oui mais alors la
il ya comme un dit on c'est parce que
beaucoup de mes mal bougé pas l'épaule
gauche la droite a mené la charge et la
gauche où ses loyers à défaut le nord
c'est ma voix si j'en avais même alors
le bhoutan la par rapport au nombril
il pense déjà aux vacances de pâques
c'est parce que vous vous tenez mal
quand je connais mon métier monsieur ya
quinze ans au carreau du temple alors
relevé la hanche droite puis mots comme
c'est pas mangé une tranche comme ça et
vous relever la hanche droite bougeait
pas bougé par les épaules écrasé vous
sur la manche gauche écrasée vous bien
sûr la hanche gauche il tente pas bien
ce thème
si je me tiens comme ça tombe bien
je me tiendrai toujours quatre
voilà voilà voilà voilà je tiendrai
toujours comme ça je suis navré tout
devant des rangées pour ces verrous noir
dans le milieu où je vis avoir un
costume menace c'est un événement alors
le clapas ils m'ont dit tiens tu vas toi
le maroc
je suis en train de penser les gens
quand ils vont voir passer dans la rue
ils vont dire suis amoureux on peut dire
qu'il a la chance d'avoir trouvé un bon
tailleur réussira si beaux costumes sur
un gars aussi mal foutu
[Applaudissements]
pas bête il a quelques doit fermer
ah oui
matin quoi y'a joueur est allumée remis
les sous marins atomiques comme un oeuf
peuvent fonctionner sous il paraît que
d'un petit repas moteur diesel ya pas de
maintenant lectrique d'autre part comme
a dit ashton j'aurais pu m'en fous moi
la paix avec ça
comment ils peuvent fonctionner des sous
marins atomiques atomiques sous l'eau
dis papa c'est étudié pour je comprends
bien seulement tu vois depuis quelque
temps les russes ont réussi des choses
extraordinaires
ils ont envoyé un enjeu qui a eu qui a
réussi à à l'unir or je ne pense pas que
l'être moeurs moi je n'ai que 9 ans et
demi et avec les nouvelles instructions
scolaire je ne sais pas grand chose mais
je crois savoir que l'être humain ne
pourra pas aller dans une autre planète
puisqu'il ya des étoiles qui sont à des
milliards d'années lumière
or nous on a du mal à venir à 81
comment se fait-il que l'on que l'on
puisse aller un jour dans une planète
malgré cache-t-elle a dit plus on va
vite plus de temps les cours fou - la
paix avec h tél je veux pas d'histoires
avec les voisins
mais pas face étudié pour nous c'est
mashala d'abord pose pas des questions
sans frais je suis ça veut dire des
matin le ballet sous marins atomiques
j'ai du mal à rouler en ré louvre
commande ou je sache rigolo ça
fonctionne pose moi des questions
sensées qu'un enfant puisse poser à son
père et je te répondrais pourquoi tous
les matches elles ont dix cornes et puis
qu'il ait choisi un an par s'étudier
pour papa quoi à l'école pendant trois
heures et nous en france ils nous ont
fait chanter quatre et trois fois que
c'était 2 4 et 3,4 et 3,7 tâter 3,7 puis
l'après-midi nous en mx 2 5 et 2
c'est pitié pour papa wap l'autre jour w
et en voyant cette pluie qui créent sur
le sol quelques petits rue qui allait
grossir des ruisseaux qui eux mêmes dans
mon imagination elle est amplifiée des
fleurs je voyais ces fleurs avec leurs
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau qui
rendrait constamment dans les océans des
fleuves comme l'amazone le congo la
nouvelle jour constamment des milliards
ça m'intrigue passe à savoir que des
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau costa
main
l'annuelle jours qui vont amplifier les
océans pourquoi tu les océans et
finissent pas par déborder et les
éponges qui est en fait
papa totaux moi qui suis ta grand mère
je vous la belle-mère foutez moi la paix
en ces mots go il me pose des questions
et il a le droit de s'instruire
[Applaudissements]
au même mademoiselle employés des ptt
vous êtes derrière votre guichet là haut
monsieur vous dormez hoya taxes en tant
que cela m'est automne
qu'est ce que vous faites mais toto si
vous faites votre chouchou
enfin dans le bureau de poste c'est bien
votre guichet il faut s'adresser pour
téléphoner au et rose est pénible qu est
ce que vous venez téléphoné à qui
voudrait le 22 à asnières pourrait pas y
aller en vélo non à nous à nous le
central c'est pas la voix zézette
comme aurait dit êtes ici c'est monique
que tu fais au centre and onta muté ça
va s'arrêter dans ses habits à la salle
wagram hommage iv pu annoncer trans
noble et ta soeur elle est malade on
attend mieux
tant mieux tant mieux la sécurité
sociale comme ça elle pour aller danser
toute la semaine
pourquoi tu sais tu m'a appelé c'est moi
qui t'ai appelé athènes à quel tour et
ouhlala vous là qu'est ce que vous
voulez où je voudrais le 22 à asnières à
l'eau passe moi le 22 à asnières
c'est ça tu me rappelles tu vois je
t'embrasse à quoi ça sert aussi pour
mort
vous pensez que ça va être lent pour les
passants a forcément et tous les fils
qu'il ya du nouveau au pardon aux prises
[Musique]
en france en seine francisco san
francisco for you cette fois très fife
san francisco x6 il n'a rien compris à
ce qu'on m'a dit
san francisco 6 4 3 2 x 5
allô allô oui cabine radio s'il vous
plaît c'est pour çà francisco san
francisco en pennsylvanie je devrais le
6325 x5 à san francisco
tu l'as directement dans la rade une
crème bien san francisco cabine 6
ils m'ont même dit derek jeter mon vélo
et puis je croyais en vidant alors comme
je dois être présenté à ma future
belle-mère alors si jamais j'arrive à
être extraites pardon sur bonjour moi
comme excuse
mademoiselle j'aimerais avoir une fois
liège monsieur van hapert du proc un
vent de vente à bruch 75 bulls comics et
good hit 75 combien que ça 75 ans à 1,95
moins 20
je voudrais avoir une fois liège
monsieur viendrait pas voir des prix de
vente très 21.21 truc je me souviens
plus du tout vrai numéro de téléphone je
suis pas sous tu vas peut-être un peu ma
femme ce n'est pas parce que cette femme
qui me suis toujours là bonjour je m'en
fous avec la vierge est bien à france à
peut-être un peu mais je sais qu'ils les
charcutiers
pensez vous que ce soit possible dans
l'air sympa bien ce cours d'eau à 6 mois
liège/bel djoum oui à l'audit ans il
faudra un vendeur vendre comment il
évoquant des îles et broc bruch
il évoque alors n'a pas l'adresse on n'a
pas le téléphone mais on croit savoir
qui les charcutiers t'as qu'à regarder
dans les professions atteint déjà tu
cherches tu l'as tu l'as trouvé très
bien
viège cabine 5
émond lanières
nommé guidon êtes pas tous à lui sinon
comment c'est un peu l'anglais par leurs
excuses et moi fera laine et un spa
sanji deutsch furent berline m car on
fonce sans faille
alexandra plaque ce téléphone of heroes
nous 35 buts et mario moi ici ce qu'il
veut
allo passé - berlin à l'an dernier
ias ifrs parisse
j'habite un téléphone iphone l'appli
iphone strass téléphone c'est rooney de
santi écoutant ce que je te dis si tu
pars toujours fait à samsic comme deux
fois douces ya bien oui berlin table in
5 face berline de cabine function
pitchen au final
et montmagny
vous pourriez pas me passer new york
pour de savoir ce que voulait non je new
york
c'est mon droit non séoul est nous y
sommes venus à bout de la chine m'en
fous alors un long passé moi nous ya non
new york tout simplement
new york 13 merci thank you new york
cabine 1 vous pourriez pas me passer le
22 à asnières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
garçon garçon s'il vous plaît je
voudrais un café crème avec deux croix
sable je m'excuse monsieur nous n'avons
plus du tout de croix semble bien ça
fait rien alors je vais prendre autre
chose ça fait il y en a tellement dans
nuit entre nous un chacun dans sa vie
privée on n'a que des soucis l on va pas
s'en faire entre nous avec a donné un
café nature à leur café nature avec deux
croient ça
je m'excuse je me suis peut-être pas
l'exprimer je vous dis que les
croissants nous n'en avons plus on n'a
plus du tout croissant là ça change tout
si on appuie je peux pas en avoir
forcément ça fait rien je parle d'autre
chose alors je prends votre porte quoi
du lait j'ai dû les abandonner moins
d'une tasse de lait avec deux croient ça
ça va pas vous êtes un peu fatigué ou
non je vous dis que les croissants en
avons plus c'est ce que c'est que les
croise un croissant des preds elle des
brioches oui des croissants non faut pas
vous en avez pour ça mais ça fait rien
écoutez je suis pas le client en beta je
vous dire donnez moi ce que vous voulez
je peux pas mieux vous dire du thé et du
chocolat
decroix sa vie d'avant et pour longtemps
habité ce garçon je vous connais pas moi
je suis client monsieur je suis comme
vous j'étais derrière la colonne vous
m'avez peut-être pas vu mais moi je vous
ai entendu vous n'êtes pas malade lors
qu'est ce qui vous prend dans petit
garçon et gna gna gna gna gna gna
taisez vous laissez moi vous dire
monsieur que vous avez de la chance
d'avoir à faire un garçon qui a de la
patience parce que moi un garçon si
j'avais à votre place il ya longtemps
que j'aurais pris les deux croissants
je les aurai [ __ ] sur la gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]